hello and welcome to the anthropocene
reviewed
a podcast where we review different
facets of the human-centered planet
on a five-star scale today
in this podcast's first ever one review
episode
i'll be reviewing aldewang sein a song
that is today
most associated with new year's eve
i find it fascinating that in a world
where so much
is so new we welcome new years
by singing a very old song
the chorus starts out for old langs ein
my joe
for zein i'll take a cup of kindness yet
for old lang zine
joe is a scot's word that can be
straightforwardly translated to
deer but aldlang sein is more
complicated
it literally means something like old
long
since but it's idiomatically similar
to the old times we have a phrase in
english
somewhat similar to for old lang sein
the phrase is for old time's sake
here's a bit of my old long sense
in the summer of 2001 the writer amy
kraus rosenthal
emailed booklist magazine to inquire
about a review
at the time i was working for booklist
as a publishing assistant
most of my job was data entry but i also
answered many of the low priority emails
that came in
so i responded to amy with an update on
the status of the review
and i also mentioned that on a personal
note i had loved her
zine like column in might magazine
i told her i often thought about one bit
she'd written
which went every time i'm flying and the
captain announces the beginning of our
descent
the same thing goes through my mind
while we're still pretty high above the
city
i'll think if the plane went down now we
would definitely
not be okay a bit lower
and no we still wouldn't be okay
but as we get real close to the ground
i'll relax
okay we're low enough now if it crashed
now
we might be okay she wrote me back the
next day
and asked if i was a writer and i said i
was trying to be
and she asked if i had anything that was
two minutes long
that might work on the radio
[Music]
we don't really know when ald lang syne
was written
the first verse goes should old
acquaintance be forgot
and never brought to mind should old
an old laying sign versions of that
date back at least 400 years but we owe
the current song
to the great scottish poet robert burns
in december of 1788 he wrote to his
friend
francis dunlop is not the scotch phrase
auld lang syne exceedingly expressive
there's an old song in tune which is
often thrilled through my soul
light be the turf on the breast of the
heaven-inspired poet
who composed this glorious fragment
and on the back of the letter burns
wrote the first known draft
of all glanzine at least three of the
verses were probably his own
although he would later say of the song
that he quote took it down
from an old man
part of what makes dating various lines
within the song difficult
is the song's eternality it's about
drinking together
and remembering old times and almost
every
idea within it from picking daisies
to wandering through fields to toasting
old friends over a beer
could have been written five hundred a
thousand or
even three thousand years ago it's also
a rousing ode to splitting the check
incidentally
with part of the second verse going and
surely you'll buy your pint cup
and surely all by mine but mostly
the song is just an unapologetic
celebration
of the good old days and of looking back
upon them
i guess i should tell you that amy is
dead
otherwise her death within this review
might seem like
some kind of narrative device which
i don't want so okay
she is dead the rare present tense
sentence
that once it becomes true stays true
forever
but we aren't there yet we were still in
the past i think
she asked me if i had anything for the
radio and i sent her three little essays
and she liked one of them and asked me
to come in
and record it for her show on chicago's
public radio station
wbez in the broadcast you could hear the
nerves in my voice
it was the first time i'd ever reached
such a large audience
after that amy invited me to be on her
show more often
and within a year i was recording
frequent commentaries for wbez
and then for npr's all things considered
sometimes amy took me out to lunch she
was everything i wanted to be
happily married a committed and loving
parent
and a successful writer she was also
incredibly good at gift giving at her
first lunch
i told her that when i moved to chicago
my mom asked me to carry forty dollars
with me
in my left pants pocket whenever i went
outside
so i would have something to give anyone
who might want to mug me
and i told amy that i still always kept
40 bucks
in my left pocket and that i tried never
to spend my mugging money
except in cases of real need
the next time we met amy surprised me
with two gifts
one was a money clip engraved with my
initials
jmg and the other was a money clip
engraved with
mm mugging money
in april of 2002 amy convened some of
her writer
and musician friends for an event at the
chopin theater
in chicago called writer's block party
she asked me to read for it and i did
and people laughed at my dumb jokes
and amy hired someone to walk around the
theater
giving everyone compliments and the
complimenter said they liked my shoes
which were these brand new adidas
sneakers
and that is why i have worn adidas
sneakers almost every day
for the last 17 years
robert burns originally had a different
tune in mind for old langston
than the one most of us know and
although he himself realized the air
was quote mediocre you will still
sometimes hear that original arrangement
it is used for example in the noted 2008
film
sex in the city but the melody most of
us know
first appeared in 1799 in george
thompson's
select songs of scotland by then
robert burns was gone he was only 37
when he died of a heart condition
possibly exacerbated by his habit of
raising many a pint glass to old
acquaintances
in his last letter he wrote to francis
dunlop an illness which has long hung
about me
in all probability will speedily send me
beyond that born
when snow traveler returns
but the song was just getting started
within decades it became a popular part
of new year's eve celebrations in
scotland
a holiday known as hogmanay that can
trace its history back to winter
solstice rituals
by 1818 beethoven had written an
arrangement of it
and it was beginning to travel
throughout europe and the
english-speaking world
today aldlang zein is often played at
japanese department stores just before
they close
between 1945 and 1948 the tune was used
in south korea's national anthem
in the netherlands its melody inspired
one of the country's most famous
football chants and it's a staple of
film soundtracks
from charlie chaplin's 1925 movie the
gold rush
to it's a wonderful life in 1946
to minions in 2015.
i think aldrenzine is popular in
hollywood not just because it's in the
public domain
and therefore cheap but also because
it's the rare song that is genuinely
wistful it acknowledges human longing
without romanticizing it and it captures
how each new year is a product of all
the old ones
when i sing alderaan sein on new year's
eve
i forget the words like everyone does
until i get to the fourth verse
which i do have memorized we too have
paddled in the stream
from morning sun till dying but seas
between us broad have roared since ald
lang syne
and i think about the many broad seas
that have roared
between me and the past seas of neglect
seas of time seas
of death i'll never speak again to many
of the people
who loved me into this moment just as
you
will never speak to many of the people
who loved you
into your now and so we raise a glass to
them
and hope that perhaps somewhere they
are raising a glass to us
in her strange and beautiful interactive
memoir
textbook amy cross rosenthal amy wrote
if one is generously contracted 80 years
that amounts to 29 220 days on earth
playing that out how many times then
really do i get to look at a tree
12 395
there has to be an exact number let's
just say it's 12
395. absolutely that is a lot
but it is not infinite and anything less
than infinite
seems too measly a number and is not
satisfactory
in her writing amy often sought to
reconcile
the infinite nature of consciousness and
love
and yearning with the finite nature
of the universe and all that inhabits it
toward the end of textbook she wrote a
multiple choice question
in the alley there is a bright pink
flower
peeking out through the asphalt a
it looks like futility b
it looks like hope for me at least
baldwin's ein captures exactly what it
feels like
to see a bright pink flower peeking out
through the asphalt
and how it feels to know that you have
12 395 times
to look at a tree
in 2005 amy published a memoir in the
form of an encyclopedia
called encyclopedia of an ordinary life
that book ends i was here you see
i was another sentence
that once it becomes true never stops
being true
that book came out just a few months
before my first novel
looking for alaska soon thereafter
my wife sarah got into graduate school
at columbia
and so we moved to new york amy and i
stayed in touch
and collaborated occasionally over the
next decade
i played a bit part in an experience she
curated for hundreds of people
on august 8 2008 in chicago's millennium
park
but it was never again like it had been
in those early days
she found out she had cancer not long
after
finishing textbook amy cross rosenthal
and she called me
she knew that in the years after the
fault in our stars was published
i'd come to know many young people who
were gravely ill
and she wanted to know if i had advice
for her
i told her what i think is true that
love
survives death but she wanted to know
how young people react to death
how her kids would she wanted to know
if her kids and her husband would be
okay
or how she could make it okay for them
and that ripped me up although i'm
usually quite comfortable talking with
sick people
with my friend i found myself stumbling
over words overwhelmed with my own
sadness and worry they won't be
okay of course but they will go on
and the love you poured into them will
go on
that's what i should have said but what
i actually said
while crying was how can this be
happening
you do so much yoga
[Music]
in my experience dying people often have
wonderful stories
of the horrible things that healthy
people say to them
but i've never heard of anybody saying
anything
close to as stupid as you do so much
yoga
i hope that amy got some narrative
mileage
out of me saying something so profoundly
idiotic in her hour of need
but i also know i failed her after she
was there for me so many times
i know she forgives me but still
i desperately wish i could have said
something useful
or perhaps not said anything at all
when people we love are suffering
we want to make it better but sometimes
often in fact you can't make it better
i'm reminded of something my supervisor
said to me when i was a student chaplain
at a children's hospital don't just do
something
stand there aldrangzhein
was a popular song in world war one
versions of it were sung
in trenches not just by british soldiers
but by french and german and austrian
ones as well
and the song even played a small role in
one of the strangest
and most beautiful moments in world
history the christmas truce
of 1914 on christmas eve
that year in part of the war's western
front
in what is now belgium around a hundred
thousand
british and german soldiers emerged from
their trenches
and met each other in the so-called no
man's land
between their front lines one
19-year-old british soldier wrote his
mother
yesterday the british and germans met
and shook hands in the ground
between the trenches and exchanged
souvenirs
marvelous isn't it a german soldier
remembered that a british soldier quote
brought a soccer ball from their
trenches
and pretty soon a lively game ensued
how marvelously wonderful yet how
strange it was
elsewhere on the front captain sir
edward hulse
recalled a christmas sing-along that
quote
ended up with aldlang zein which we all
english scots irish prussians
wutenbergers etc joined in
it was absolutely astounding and if i
had seen it on cinematograph
film i should have sworn it was faked
hulse who was 25 years old at the time
would be killed on the western front
less than four months later
at least 17 million people would die
as a direct result of the war more than
half the current population of canada
by christmas of 1916 soldiers didn't
want truces
the devastating losses of the war and
the growing use of poison gas
had embittered the combatants but many
also had no idea why they were fighting
and dying for tiny patches of ground
so far from home and in the british
trenches
soldiers began to sing the tune of
aldhlang zein
with different words we're here
because we're here because we're here
because we're here
here was a world without wise
where life was meaningless all the way
down
modernity had come to war and the rest
of life
the art critic robert hughes once
referred to the quote
peculiarly modernist hell of repetition
and the trenches of world war one were
hell indeed
[Music]
although she was a playful and
optimistic writer
amy was not deluded about the nature of
suffering
or about its centrality in human life
her work whether picture book or memoir
always finds a way to acknowledge misery
without giving into it one of the last
lines
she ever wrote was death may be knocking
on my door
but i'm not getting out of this glorious
bath to answer
it
in her public appearances amy would
sometimes
use that recursive lament of british
soldiers
and transform it without ever changing
the tune
or the words she would ask an audience
to sing that song with her we're here
because we're here because we're here
because we're here and although
it is of course a profoundly nihilistic
song
written about the modernist hell of
repetition
singing that song with amy i could
always see the hope in it
it became a statement that we are here
meaning that we are together and not
alone
and it's also a statement that we are
that we
exist and it's a statement that we are
here that a series of astonishing
unlikelihoods
has made us possible and here
possible we might never know why
we are here but we can still proclaim
in hope that we are here
i don't think such hope is foolish or
idealistic
or misguided i believe that hope
is for lack of a better word
true we live in hope
that life will get better and more
importantly
that it will go on that love will
survive
even though we will not as emily
dickinson put it
hope is the thing with feathers that
perches in the soul
and sings the tune without the words
and never stops at all
and we are here because we are here
because we're here because we're here
sing it with me wherever you are
think of those across the broad and
roaring seas
and sing with me you won't be more off
tune
than i am
we're here because we're here
because we're here because we're here
because we're here because we're
here
i give although anxiety five stars
[Music]
[Applause]
here because we're here